bonjour gaël durel
merci beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin
dans la matinale berthet france vous
avez donc signé cette tribune pour
appeler un vrai débat sur l'hôpital est
ce que vous pensez être entendu en fin
donc la réponse à partir de 17 mars on
verra comment est ce que les candidats
répondent à cette invitation et viennent
avec leurs propositions et de voir si
les propositions qu'on leur soumet ce
jour tant sont conformes à leur
programme et peuvent en effet apporter
de vraies réponses par rapport aux défis
qui s'annoncent dans les années à venir
pour notre système de santé en france
parce que ce que vous demandez c'est que
les candidats viennent et phases de
vraies propositions concrètes pour
améliorer la la situation dans les
hôpitaux que l'on connaît un jeu c'est
pas que simplement dans les hôpitaux
puisque moi je représente le
médico-social donc avec les ehpad
établissement personnes âgées
dépendantes en s'élançant du système de
santé c'est pas uniquement hospitalier
ça correspond aussi dans tous les
territoires d'accès aux soins pour toute
personne qu'elle puisse trouver un
médecin sur son territoire avec les
problématiques des déserts médicaux les
pratiques d'accès aux soins les
problématiques de rendez-vous de
permanence des soins double de projets
beaucoup plus large que celui simplement
de la réforme hospitalière après deux
ans de pandémie vous déploré le fait que
cette question ne soit pas vraiment
évoqué dans dans les débats et est aussi
traitée par le gouvernement
donc le gouvernement donc est préoccupé
bien sûr par la question sanitaire et et
pour cela donc les mesures sont prises
donc on voit bien qu'on est dans une
réponse qui semble adapté à notre
situation économique et sanitaire mais
par contre donc le débat sur l la santé
nous que depuis plusieurs donc mon
nature ne semble pas à la hauteur des
enjeux donc avec des blancs qui se sont
succédé mais qui n'ont pas apporté les
réponses auxquelles les français peuvent
attendre des primes des augmentations de
salaire pour pour les soignants mais
pour vous le ségur de la santé
finalement n'a pas apporté de réponse
il a apporté une forme de réponse mais
ne qu'encore une fois donc il faut pas
centré simplement le problème de santé
sur l'hôpital
la santé de dissuasion de bien-être
c'est pas simplement donc être exemple
maladie c'est de pouvoir répondre à
toutes les préoccupations qui sont pas
simplement que sanitaire mais c'est
aussi de la qualité de vie de la
personne qui permet d'avoir une
meilleure santé donc il faut que les
propositions soient plus large que celle
simplement d'une réforme hospitalière
parler du médico social il y à des
manifestations aujourd'hui du secteur
pour des augmentations de salaires un
rendez vous devait être pris avec le
ministre pour en parler le 15 janvier la
réunion n'a pas lieu ou le déplorer
je ne suis pas syndicaliste donc
l'association que je préside
donc m corps est une association d
expertise qui apporte une expertise à
yathrib doute dans le médico social mais
o2 encore une fois des réformes
salariales qui sont importantes de
revaloriser le travail c'était à bâle
apporter un nombre suffisant rénover
l'hôpital il faut aussi attirer de
nouveau les personnels soignants dedans
dans le secteur c'est la grosse
problématique que l'on contractuellement
c'est qu'on a beaucoup de mal à trouver
des remplaçants donc notamment dans
cette situation co-lead donc qu'à
contacter personnel de tout chez eux
mêmes par la maladie font qu'on est dans
une grande difficulté à trouver des
remplacements donc l'attractivité donc
au sens large du système de santé n'est
pas à la hauteur des enjeux encore il
faut ne s'est pas simplement au niveau
des médecins infirmiers mais c'est tout
le système de santé aides soignants de
kmp éducateur il faut trouver des
nouvelles vocations et leur donner envie
de travailler dans le syndicat dans le
médico-social donc en devenir des
conditions de travail ça passe par une
revalorisation salariale mais ça passe
aussi par des conditions de travail il
ya d'avoir un nombre de soignants
suffisant pour s'occuper des personnes
crise des vocations aujourd'hui
oui donc on peut parler de crise de
vocations n'oubliez donc une difficulté
à trouver des personnes qui ont envie de
s'engager donc d'enseignés de la santé
parce qu'ils sentent que l'organe
donc avoir un beau métier qui est un
métier passionnant et kate un métier au
contact humain qui est extraordinaire
les messieurs le fait de caunes et en
muscles et en étant donc avec des
rythmes d'aucun inferno donc des repos
qui sont limitées des vacances qu'on ne
peut pas prendre parce qu'on n'a pas de
remplaçant pour les prendres ne sait
donc limite l'accès à ces personnes dans
le site à de santé pourquoi avoir signé
cette tribu que souhaitez-vous
voir aboutir en tout cas rapidement
c'est vraiment de faire passer également
le message que le médico social dans le
sens du système de santé doc et est donc
nécessaire pour pouvoir ou pas de cette
réforme est nécessaire et pas simplement
l'hôpital nous qu'il faut donc élargir
l'ensemble des propositions aux
territoires au personnel aux projets de
kova de santé en france et le fait que
les candidats
viendrait en tout cas faire leurs
propositions ça ça aiderait à sortir des
solutions
c'est déjà donc de montrer aux français
que donc leur poser la question vous
allez voter pour un candidat est ce que
les problématiques de santé sont au
coeur de la préoccupation donc donc tout
le monde est prêt à avoir un meilleur
système de santé ce que tout le monde
est prêt à le payer donc on prend
souvent des exemples avec des pays
européens des pays nordiques donc nous
devons regarder les ratios le personnel
si je prends le cas d'un homme de médico
social ce ne sont pas les mêmes donc ce
sont des choix politiques à faire si
vous voulez deux fois plus de soignants
pour s'occuper de votre personne âgée
d'une grand mère dans un ehpad elle va
falloir que les moyens soient apportées
des moyens il faut que de trouver
d'argent pour le payer et de cet argent
là il va falloir que nos que les
candidats de 10 ou est ce qu'ils se
trouvent comment est ce qui les
financent quels sont vos projets pour
apporter cette attractivité et le
financement donc des réformes qui sont
nécessaires aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
on suivra évidemment ce rendez vous du
17 mars et et voir s'il est suivi ou pas
en tout cas merci beaucoup qu'elle dure
elle d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct
à nos questions sur rt france